[Music]
have you ever thought about where your
leftover food goes after you throw it in
the trash
or the consequences that it has for our
planet
in the u.s alone about 37 million tons
of discarded food
were brought to landfills in 2015
that's equal to the weight of 100 empire
state buildings
in landfills food scraps and other
organic material
are broken down by bacteria in the
absence of oxygen
which produces methane a potent
greenhouse gas with even greater
capacity
to trap heat in our atmosphere than
carbon dioxide
composting is an eco-friendly
alternative to discarding our food waste
with three
important advantages first composting
allows food scraps to degrade in the
presence of oxygen
meaning no methane is produced
second composting mimics natural
nutrient recycling processes
breaking down biodegradable materials to
produce organic fertilizer
a sustainable alternative to synthetic
fertilizers that require high amounts of
fossil fuel energy
to produce third composting diverts
waste from landfills preserving natural
ecosystems that would otherwise be
cleared for landfill use
and the best part you can compost in
your own backyard
click the link in the description to
learn more
[Music]
you